- Good morning everybody.
Hope can you hear me?
So thanks for being here today.
My name is Christian Finelli,
I'm a senior solution architect at AWS,
part of the Telco Business Unit.
Today we'll be learning how Ericsson
are transforming their in
house development experience
with AI on AWS.
We'll have Bastian and
Dag talking about that
in the next session.
Now, Ibrahim and I will talk you through
on how Ericsson are
optimizing their customers
mobile network experience with AI on AWS.
So AWS is working with CSP,
communication service providers,
to achieve their business objectives,
which are increase revenue,
optimize cost, and reduce customer churn.
CSPs are migrating and modernizing
complex BSS and OSS stacks on AWS.
They do that to reduce time to market
and increase product agility.
At the same time,
they migrate complex IT workloads
to increase operational
efficiency through AI automation.
CSPs are also migrating
virtualizing network functions
on AWS.
They do that to increase
elasticity, scalability,
and also to increase business continuity
through disaster recovery options on AWS.
Also CSPs are transforming
their customer experience
to basically everything starts with data,
the way they model customers' behavior
and the way they can provide
a personalized customer
experience for their CSPs.
Lastly, AWS and CSPs are
working together tightly
to build and think beyond connectivity,
build new revenue streams,
and protecting and monetizing
existing network investment.
They explore new business models
and they, as part of that
software as a service,
for example, is something
that gives them the option
to explore new pricing structures
and build and increase
agility of their product line.
AI is a key component in all these areas,
and we are seeing that Ericsson
as a key AWS partner
is best positioned to
scale this initiative.
Some of these initiatives
we'll see at scale globally.
As a matter of fact,
Ericsson are transforming
their business and their
product lines with AI and ML.
So let me bring a few examples
on how they're achieving that.
So they're reducing the
product delivery time
by leveraging agents
to integrate complex
software stacks in the field.
They're optimizing mobile
natural performance
for their customers CSPs
by leveraging a combination
of traditional ML
and agentic AI solutions.
They're also reducing time to
bring new features to market,
features that are delivered
and they are implemented
by team, internal teams
by building a ML ops platform
to accelerate adoption of ML technologies.
And also they are empowering
their large base of software developers
to improve their efficiency
to build better products.
We are working closely with Ericsson,
we are at firsthand experience
what it means building a
successful agentic AI solution.
It's not just identifying
and picking a LLM
and or adopting an agentic SDK.
And everything that
they complete AI stacks
so the accuracy and the economical
viability of the AI stack
underpinning the agentic AI solution
is a critical factor for its success.
There are few areas we've identified.
We start off from the fact that
the business must be able to trust agents
and the output of these agents.
So this means access to data
and to knowledge authorized
at the lowest ground level.
At the same time, it's important to,
in a traditional ML training,
data lineage plays a key role
in keeping track of origin of data
for data sovereignty requirements.
Also, trust comes with explainability,
being able to determine, to dissect
how agents behave,
the turns they take,
the reasoning process,
and also the different tools they call
and the performance of this.
Also as a next step is the
fact that context is king.
So the way context,
the way knowledge and data are
delivered at the right time
to the right agent concisely,
because size means cost,
it's also another element for success.
We also see that in a
multi-agentic solution
where there are multiple
agents working in combination,
it's important to attribute
value to each agent.
And when we say value is that
the overall outcome of
the multi agentic solution
is the value is split
across different agents
and determining what
value each agents bring
along with the cost allows
determination of autonomic ROI
for each agent.
This goes into really explainability
Observability is the foundation
for operational excellence.
So being able to understand and monitor
end to end performance of
these agents, as we said,
and also being able to operate them.
But when we said agents is
also not just operations,
agent operations,
but also everything that falls
into the underlying AI stack,
so LLM operations, ML operations.
Last also being able to run
these operations efficiently
through AI SDSC capabilities.
Ibrahim, you might wanna talk to us
what importance for why explainability
is important for customers.
- Thank you very much, Christian.
One thing I think we understand,
people who work very
closely with agentic AI,
and agents are not just about
deployment of technology.
When a CSP, a service provider,
is basically sourcing
agents from Ericsson,
they trust an outcome that
comes out from this agent.
They are basically
outsourcing network operation
for a national infrastructure
to someone like Ericsson.
So for them, it's extremely important
that we have explainability
in the whole stack.
Why a decision by agent is like that,
why my workflow is designed this way,
and what are the tools
and why the tools that,
as I will explain in the coming slides,
why these tools are making
such kind of decisions
to implement changes
in a national infrastructure like telco.
So explainability is extremely important
and the stack that AWS provides
actually gives us the
tools and the capabilities
to have this explainability to CSPs.
Explainability and
observability, right, Christian?
- [Christian] Absolutely.
Thank you Ibrahim.
- Thank you.
- And the observability, as Ibrahim said,
is across not just, as I said,
not just across the agentic AI layer,
but across the whole AI stack.
Ericsson are leveraging different services
from the AWS AI stacks.
We will see both use cases how
they leverage these services,
but the stacks cover
service multiple personas
for different business cases.
So we start off from the bottom layer
where data scientists use AI compute
to run training jobs
and host model for inference
from GPU to Amazon own chips.
Amazon SageMaker AI is
used by data scientists
to run the entire ML
ops for their ML models.
So preparing data, training the model,
evaluating models continuously
throughout their life cycle,
hosting models for inference,
and then monitoring
the model performances.
Moving up the stack,
engineers and developer use Amazon Bedrock
to run agents at scale
securely in production.
This gives them choice
of foundational models
and give them capabilities
to allow to run that
at scale and securely.
Also, agentic SDLC applications
are leveraged by developers
to increase their efficiency
in coding, in developing software,
but also in maintaining
throughout all the operations.
So today we have firsthand experience,
two teams from Ericsson coming on stage
to discuss these two use cases.
The first one is Cognitive
Natural Solutions, CNS.
So they're leveraging,
they're using a combination
of traditional ML inference
and a multi agentic
solution to optimize CSP's
mobile natural performance.
And then System Comprehension Lab,
they empower their Ericsson engineers
to build better products through AI.
I'll leave the stage to you, Ibrahim.
- Thank you again, Christian.
So let me take you through our journey
of partnership together with AWS
in building this agentic AI for CSPs.
But before I take you
through this journey,
I would like you to
understand a little bit
what we stand for for Ericsson.
What's our mission and what is the impact
that we're actually having on society?
5G networks today, there are around 340,
189 of them are actually running
using Ericsson innovation.
So that's more than 50%
of 5G networks worldwide.
And more than 50% of worldwide
5G traffic outside China
is running in our own equipment.
I can tell you that here you are in Vegas,
if you are having mobile
services from AT&T,
Verizon or T-Mobile,
it's a hundred percent the chance
that you are using Ericsson Innovate.
CSPs are using Ericsson innovation
to deliver the service to you.
This is the impact that
we are having on society.
This is the impact that we
are providing to the world.
And in order to make
sure that these services
are provided like best in class,
we have a heritage of innovation
that extends 150 years.
Most like, you know, the most
obvious thing that you see
is the number of patents
that we bring for mobile technology,
more than 60,000 patents.
What actually proves that
this kind of technology
or this kind of innovation
is providing value
is that more than 74% of worldwide CSPs,
they always come first
when they're benchmarked
against their competition in the market
when they're using Ericsson equipment.
So for us in Ericsson,
it's extremely important to make sure that
this impact on society,
what we bring to CSPs
when it comes to performance,
to innovation is top notch.
And that's why it's
important for us to partner
with someone like AWS to
provide such kind of value.
And AI is a cornerstone
of that transformation
that we provide to our customers.
So for us, we worked in
transforming our portfolio offering
on the different parts of the
stack in mobile technology
and also for network operation using AI.
So we leveraged on our own competence.
So we shifted our own competence
in order to make sure that
people inside are capable of delivering
such kind of new value
to customer using AI.
We also worked on shifting
the mindset of people
and understanding that
what it means to provide AI
in each and every offering,
making sure that we built our networks
for the such kind of AI
traffic that we see today
and we see growing in the future.
And we are also using AI
into the network operation,
and also across the stack,
as Dag is gonna explain
to us a little bit later.
So we provide this in the portfolio
of how this mobile innovation
is delivered to CSPs
and also the way that we
operate this networks.
And this is the framework
that we talk about
for autonomous networks.
So, and if I give a little bit of
a view on what we mean
by autonomous networks.
Autonomous networks is a
framework that is defined by TMF
on how we operate networks
for today and for the future.
And it is actually across
five different levels
that you see here on the slide.
One thing that I'd like to
bring to your attention is
the graph that you see below,
the percentage of CSPs today
who are barely like reaching level three,
or actually beyond level three,
is less than 10%.
And it's actually when you start to move,
when you start to have humans,
sorry, when you start to
have AI into these systems
and into network operation
is the level three plus
that we are talking about.
So you might hear and
around in the community,
or right here actually
in CSPs talking about
reaching higher level of network autonomy
and reaching level four.
We cannot reach level
four without making sure
that we are embedding AI
in the way that we operate networks
and that's why autonomous networks
is a very important framework
to bring this to our CSPs.
And the way that we realize that
in our portfolio for Telco
AI is what you see here,
what we refer to as the cognitive loop.
Five stage of actually the workflow
that we have for network operation.
Starting by measurement,
where we have measurement agents
that understand the network data
and making sure that, you know,
we are capturing the information we want
in order to move the next
step, which is assurance.
And then assurance is where we
have agents like classifiers
and root cause analyzers
who can actually tell us what's
happening in the network,
what kind of anomalies are there,
and what are the root causes
of such kind of anomalies.
And then we move to the next
step, which is proposal,
where we have AI recommender systems
and AI agents equipped
with recommendation tools
in order to propose what
is the next best action.
But obviously we understand
networks are complex.
So in order for us to make sure
that the best decision is
the final one implemented
in a network,
which is again reminding everyone,
is a national infrastructure
for each country.
This is the evaluation step
that you can see there.
And after the evaluation is done,
this is where the execution
happens and the activation,
and the cycle continues.
This is what we call the cognitive loop.
And as you can see, agentic AI fabric
is implemented in order to
have this cognitive loop
fully functioning from end to end.
And this is achieved
through different agents,
as you can see there.
So we have agents who are
specialized in certain workflows
who are getting runtime
context from the network
as the traffic shifts
and things are happening every day,
I would say also every hour.
And in order to achieve that,
we believe in openness
and we believe in horizontalization.
So the architecture that we
have built together with AWS
is basically encompassing
these two main objectives,
openness on how we get the data
and make sure that such
kind of data is exposed
to the upper layers
or like actually towards agents,
through the different services from AWS.
And these services, they'd
actually provide the agents
with different capabilities
as you see on the slide.
So leveraging, for example,
as I mentioned about the R apps,
which are tools for these agents.
This is how we actually provide the agents
with the capability to understand
what's happening in the network
and also execute the
changes on these networks.
Maybe here, again, observability
is extremely important
and not only the observability,
but the different services in the stack
that we have from AWS.
If you can share with the audience
a little bit more about that.
- Absolutely, thank you, Ibrahim.
So it all starts by ingesting
large volume of data
from a radio access network.
And as you see at the bottom there,
there's the ETL layer,
which is run on AWS services,
serverless services,
containers and fully
managed service by AWS
like Athena and Glue,
and this is for processing,
as I said, data coming from
the radio access network
and prepare them to be
consumed by an ML pipeline.
SageMaker, Amazon SageMaker AI,
that's where the ML pipeline is built
where data are prepared,
the model are trained,
model gets evaluated,
and then they are hosted for inference.
End point inference are
then invoked on our app.
So our application, which are ML powered,
which consume predictions.
So they produce predictions
about network performance
and these R apps
contribute, as Ibrahim said,
to the context of the associated agents.
The agents themselves also
rely on other data sources,
other knowledge bases
through RAG techniques.
Data that are basically product guide,
network configuration,
network data structure and correlations
amongst different network parameters.
So an agent is then able
to invoke on our app
to consume the prediction
and to retrieve relevant knowledge.
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore
then provides Ericsson with capabilities
like memory and observability
to offload these functions
on AWS managed services.
So in essence, the full stack
it plays a role SageMaker
for producing accurate
predictions through ML
and AgentCore to manage the
full life cycle of agents.
- Thank you very much Christian.
And if I go back again
to the tools that we
provide for these agents,
which basically the R apps,
the radio applications that can actually
provide such kind of prediction
and also understanding like
what's happening on the network.
One example of this is what
we call the cell shapers.
And cell shapers are
reinforcement learning agents
where we have a digital twin
representation of the network,
this is how we start.
For those of you who are familiar
with how networks are built
from a radio perspective,
the way that network has been designed
since the early times of
GSM is we have an antenna
and this antenna has a
certain coverage area.
And the very first problem
that engineers try to solve
is that how to optimize
coverage and quality.
This is a multi-generational problem
that started from 2G, 3G, 4G, 5G,
and we'll also see it in 6G
So how can we make sure that
we have the optimal coverage and capacity
and the quality in this network?
So the typical ways of working
that have been around in the
industry was to do simulations
before you even have a deployment
and before the signal is in there.
What we do with reinforcement
learning agents here,
which again, these are the
tools that we provide for agents
on AWS stack.
They reconstruct the radio
environment based on live traffic
and they always learn from
what's happening in the network.
This learning is happening
through a multi objective
reinforcement learning algorithms.
So in order to make sure that
we are always providing the best trade off
between coverage, capacity, and quality
for the different players,
and they are always
learning from the network.
So the traffic changes,
and there are different
aspects that impact that.
For example, introduction of new spectrum
or densification of sites
or maybe addition of new
technology, for example,
like Cloud RAN or like 6G on top of 5G.
So this kind of cell shapers,
they actually belong to what
we call the propose stage,
as I explained in the cognitive loop,
and they help us to realize
such kind of autonomy
on top of a stack like AWS.
And these are not the
only agents that we use.
So as you can see here,
I provided a little bit of more details
about what kind of agents
that we have developed
and we are now working together with AWS
to bring it on their stack.
So in different parts to
improve user experience,
to improve network operation,
and also to improve efficiency
in operating networks.
The numbers that you see
here are not lab results,
they're actually coming
from real field deployments
for these agents.
Basically, we are able
to measure the impact
and we understand that
the impact that we bring
like through Ericsson technology,
as I explained at the very first slide,
is very profound for the
society and for CSPs.
And here I would like to hand
over to my colleague, Dag,
so to tell us,
I told you a little bit
about how we operate.
So Dag can tell us
about how we build that.
- Thank you Ibrahim, thank you everybody.
So let's maybe take a little
bit of a step back, right,
because we have a lot of
sort of AI applications
in the networks that Ibrahim talked about.
But where does the actual
like intelligence come from?
I mean it partly comes from
like observing the network
and applying, you know,
controlled function theory and so on.
But it also comes from
the fact that we've built
mobile network infrastructure
for four decades, right?
So if we're talking about
intelligent networks,
lots of this is actually
about representing
the intelligence that
we have institutionally,
the people we have,
and the data assets that
we have in the company.
So this is why we created something called
the system comprehension lab,
which has a couple of different objectives
that I'll talk about.
But maybe the first thing to notice
is when we look out in the world,
like we look at our customers' networks,
we realize that like
a mobile network today
across a big country,
especially here in the US,
they're astoundingly complex,
they're very, very complicated
distributed systems
and they're complicated
both in deployment managing,
like Ibrahim talked about,
but they're also, you know,
quite complicated in design, right?
We have, you know, all the
different kind of radio products
we have, you know, 2G,
4G, 3G, 5G, 6G coexisting,
we have millions of configurations
that are set to operate and
configure these networks.
So our AI journey back some years ago
when we started working with with AWS
started from this notion that
to really solve an
interesting problem with AI
for Ericsson and for our customers,
it is about sort of realizing
that we have this massive,
massive system complexity
out there in the real world.
I mean, and I would say that
this is actually not like
a particularly Ericsson specific problem
and not even a telco
specific problem, right?
If you're designing air crafts
or if you're designing
nuclear power plants,
something of that nature,
you are dealing with
massive system complexity,
and AI somehow has to help you.
So we basically get to this
fundamental question for us,
are we comprehension bound?
It's not even a question at this point,
we are comprehension bound
and when I say us here,
I mean Ericsson's R&D,
we are several tens of thousands of people
and we work in this space
of distributed systems.
And so when you think about sort of,
okay, building 6G
or building the next
generation of 5G sort of,
are we bounded by the
traditional sort of three pillars
of project execution,
of cost, and scope, and time?
Or can we actually say that we
are probably more limited by
the amount of, you know, comprehension
that the humans involved
can actually apply
to these processes?
So I mean, I'm not gonna be
super self-critical about this,
as Abraham said,
half of the world's 5G traffic
goes through our product
so we're doing a good job.
But we can still say that, okay,
we're probably comprehension bound
as humans developing mobile
network infrastructure.
So then our AI mission is this notion of,
okay, how can we actually make AI work
in the limit of complex
systems engineering, right?
So again, it doesn't matter
if you think about telco,
you can think about nuclear power,
or aircraft, or whatever,
you know, cars, whatever you
want to think about, right?
So for us, the comprehension lab,
it starts from the point that,
okay, so we have
millions and millions
of documents in house.
I mean, we've been doing what we're doing
for three decades or
four decades without AI.
and sort of, okay, so
we have a first mission
to take all of our data,
our in-house data assets
and just make us better at, you know,
designing mobile networks.
And if we do that well,
and we do that with Amazon Web Services
with Bedrock and so on,
that I'll speak to in a little bit,
we sort of put down a foundation
of institutional knowledge
and sort of intelligence about
how mobile networks are built
that we can then layer
on top the kind of data
that Abraham was talking about,
which is when we actually see
these enormous data streams
of what's happening in the
live networks out there.
We can explain what that means,
we can act on that,
we can be sort of intelligently integrated
into that data flow.
And then that lays, again,
the foundations for thinking
about sort of, okay,
how do we make our products
understand our human intents
in ways that like, you know,
again, derived from the
fact that we're sort of
consolidating our institutional knowledge
that makes us better at
designing our products,
and then we are layering on top sort of
the real network telemetry
that's out there.
So, I mean, what I wanna
also mention here is that
there is a real disconnect
out there in the world.
I mean, I think we all are a
part of this information flow
where the frontier AI capabilities
that get a lot of
attention, like, you know,
competition level programming,
and competition physics,
and competition mathematics and so on,
they're opening up a very wide gap
towards the sort of reality of AI impact
in an industrial setting
or in a product development setting.
And this gap is actually much, much bigger
than what I think I try
to visualize here, right?
I mean the gap between how
much value we can generate
on our own with AI in product development
versus the state of the art, so to speak.
So we've been working a lot with AWS
to sort of say, okay, what
does it take to close this gap
for a company of Ericsson's size?
I mean, again, we're a fairly
large R&D organization,
we need to close this gap,
so we actually can deliver the value
that Ibrahim spoke about.
And this is about the challenge that,
okay, every organization
has a lot of data,
but nobody has clean data, right?
So all of these, you know,
demos you see about competition
programming and so on,
underneath of that is an
enormous amount of data work.
So one has to do that,
and one has to combine, sort of,
different kinds of data assets
across this very complicated design space
that I'm gonna mention.
Then of course,
multi-step reasoning
makes this harder, right?
So we were used to saying,
okay, wow, super nice,
now there's a new multi-step reasoning LLM
capable of helping us, but you know,
the more steps you have in reasoning,
if you're applying this to
some complex technical problem,
every step has a chance
to take you off rails
and then you sort of diverge
into nothing very, very quickly
unless you can constrain that
reasoning as we move forward.
So these are some of the challenges
that inspired us to work on AgentCore
and working with Bastian and AWS
over the last couple of years.
So what we basically mean is
information fusion, right?
I mean, we have, again, this is different
in a DevOps setting but we're,
from my standpoint, an embedded
systems company, right?
So we collect requirements,
we systemize, we develop,
we test and integrate,
we release and deploy,
and then our products are out in the field
for a decade or more.
So it is about taking a vastly complicated
sort of set of data assets
throughout this flow
and fusing them in a way
that we haven't been able to do before.
The key question then, I mean for us is,
what are the assumptions,
or what's the architecture that we need
to be able to do this at the
scale of our R&D organization,
which as I said is several tens
of thousands of developers.
The first thing we want to accomplish
is some kind of decoupling.
So you can say, okay,
we have tools like Amazon
Q Developer or Kiro
as a sort of user front end facing tool.
But that in itself doesn't know anything
about Ericsson's, you
know, internal R&D assets.
So through MCP, we sort of said,
okay, let's standardize on
MCP as that decoupling layer
between the front end tools
and whatever we design in-house.
And then we put a lot of effort
in not being sort of
end-to-end AI products,
but building sort of these
specialized AI agents,
the specialized AI
technology that is, you know,
somehow differentiating for Ericsson.
Specialized models,
specialized developer tooling,
and specialized agents.
So I mean, especially in the
specialized agents category,
I would like to invite Bastian
to talk a little bit about
different aspects of this
and how this all came together for us.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much, Dag.
All right, so thanks
Dag for talking about,
I think the concept of
being comprehension bound
is important to keep in mind here.
It's something that is
important for all enterprises
that have history, I would say, right?
And especially in R&D heavy enterprises.
So it's also great how we tackle that
with the System Comprehension Lab.
And for this, I'm gonna
talk a little bit about
what are important factors
within the system comprehension lab.
What are the key pillars
that we had to work on
to make this successful?
So on one hand, I mean we say
that the agents are the one
that interface with the humans,
but they need the right data,
and we already talked
about this quite a lot now,
that there's different data,
different data silos,
they have to be fused together.
So how do we do that?
One part of that is that
while multi-step reasoning
has its own problems,
multi-step reasoning is one of the things
that is really important for that
because we have to move
beyond the traditional,
or some people call it naive RAG,
where it's just, let me find similar text
in a tech space that you have,
it's just impossible to
get something sensible.
- Yeah.
- Or you get something,
but is it, right?
So it's important to have the system
where you actually
evaluate the user query,
where you query different user,
where we query different data sources,
combine this data and maybe, you know,
step back, think again,
maybe interact with the user again
to get to the right data
that your agent needs.
So on top of that,
so this is getting the right data,
the concise data at the
right time for the agent.
The other thing that an agent
needs to act upon this right,
is sometimes you need
to go a step further,
and I'll talk about this in
a little bit more detail,
but yes, context depends on
traditional AI ML models at some point,
but it also might need that you need
a custom large language model,
and I'll go a little bit
into why that is important
in the next step.
Multi model processing is also important.
I mean, the data that we see,
it's not like we just ingest
a very well structured text documents,
there's a lot of different
modalities in the data,
and again, also there I'll
show a little bit more detail
in the following slide.
So now we are ready to see,
like the agent can get the right data now,
well even though this is
a simplified view of this,
the agent has the right data,
what else is important for it?
Well, it is important
that it can integrate
two downstream tools.
Dag, you didn't mention that now,
but I mean there are these
agents they need to interact
with the physical or digital world, right?
I mean, this is supposed
to be for engineers
to build better products.
Engineers work with a
multitude of different tools
when they do their coding,
when they are engineering.
So maybe they need a connection
to the project planning
tool that they're using,
knowledge that they have there,
the source control tool
that they're using,
different kind of tools and
you need to have access to that
and you would like to remove
all of these paper cuts
for the user
so you hand that over to the agent.
So again, here, you said
this nicely earlier,
MCP is the layer here
that connects all of this.
How do you actually work
with this downstream system?
Well you make these tools
available through MCP
and the agent can use them
and they can use each
other through that as well.
So now we have downstream integration.
The other thing that you want to have,
well you want to surface
this information to the user,
and Ericsson follows a nice principle here
of making it available to the
user where they want to work.
So sometimes it may be the right thing
to work on a deep research
task within a browser,
so they have a dedicated
frontend for that.
And sometimes it may be
that you want to do that
directly on the IDE
where you do your coding
for a specific project
and then you wanna utilize it
directly through, for example,
Amazon Q developer or Kiro.
So agent has the right tools,
agent has the right data,
but there's more to it
and maybe the more fluffy
the non-functional pieces
that are important.
So we've already talked about
observability quite a lot.
It is important to understand
what tools are called.
Did we select the right tools?
Are they relevant for the task?
Do they get the right output?
Do we get the right context?
Is the context that where we have created
through the multi-step reasoning
actually relevant for the
question that was asked
or for the task that the
agent is supposed to work on?
Observability also goes beyond that.
I mean these systems are not just agent
and maybe a model somewhere,
those are complex,
or at least complicated systems
with many moving pieces.
So you have your regular application,
you have your models,
but you also have data sources,
you have pipelines to
process data and all of that.
So there's a lot of things
that need to keep track on,
so observability is utmost of importance.
Then scalable architecture,
I'm not gonna focus too much
on the technical piece of that,
also that's important, right?
And Ericsson is using AgentCore,
so Bedrock AgentCore,
as one of the main core pieces
of that to make that easy
so you get this serverless experience
of running your agents,
but there is another part to scalability,
and that's the organizational scalability.
In essence, what you have here
is a two-sided marketplace
where you have teams that have
expertise in certain domains
and they want to make this available.
They wanna make this available
through these agents,
but they may not
necessarily want to become
experts in agentic AI,
or how to train models.
That's maybe not what they want to do.
So you need to be able
to onboard these teams
and their knowledge quickly,
and this is what Ericsson
is doing really nicely
with blueprints and actually
agents to help onboard teams
onto the system.
So two-sided marketplace,
well you have the producer side
and you have the consumer side.
The consumers also need
to be able to be onboard
and there's enablement,
there is making sure that
they're using the system
in a way that it makes sense
from a limit perspective.
So are they overusing that?
I mean there's cost involved with LLMs.
So is this working right?
You also need to be able to make sure
that these users can access
the tools that they should,
but probably not everything, right?
So there's a certain amount of
authentication authorization
involved here as well.
So that's the scalable architecture piece.
Lastly, but it's not the least,
it's actually something that
I personally talk about first
in every meeting when there
is agentic AI use case,
evaluation needs to come first.
The only constant that you
have in agentic AI projects
is change,
and it's a very high velocity
change that we see here.
So the only way that you
can actually keep up with
the latest model that you want to try,
the latest technique and
pattern that you want to try,
or simply update the data that you have,
is you need to be able to understand,
is this change that are introduced now
at least as good as yesterday?
And that only works if you build
a robust evaluation
framework from day one.
All right, moving on into something.
I'll take some time to explain
certain parts of the system
if we want to talk about
this system in its entirety,
we have a couple of days in front of us,
so I'll focus on some things
that I think are really critical.
First one is the data processing piece.
Data processing is
complicated in this sense,
it's actually one of the
most complicated pieces
of the entire thing.
And this is highly simplified,
but I just wanna run through
the most important pieces.
So we basically have,
well, we have the data,
the raw data, and this
is the hardest part.
We have a pipeline that
makes sense of this data,
that processes this data
and then makes it
available in data storage
that is useful for the
specific task for the agents.
On the data side,
problem is, well this
is not homogeneous data.
You have data in many different formats,
whether that is your PDF, Word document,
a image of a napkin somewhere,
you have lots of different data.
On top of that, you also have data
that is super well structured
and that may come from
a relational database.
And on the other hand you
have super unstructured data
spread around your data lake.
How do you make sense of that?
And then the third dimension in data
is maturity or authority.
So what does it mean?
Is this something that I can trust?
Is this something that can give me
a definitive and authoritative answer?
So since in this data sources,
you have everything from specifications,
like maybe you have a
3GPP specification too,
coming back to the napkin,
some napkin of an idea
that some engineers drew during lunch.
It's different kind of data
that you need to evaluate
differently by the agent.
So now you have this pieces
moving over to the data processing part.
Ericsson uses AWS Batch
and other services in here from AWS
to make the most out of this data.
Sometimes it's about
integration to the data sources,
but the more interesting parts are
how do I actually extract the metadata
'cause when you extract an image
from a document that you have,
you want to make sure that
where does it come from?
Does it fit to that document?
Where's this document coming from?
Can I resurface this later on?
But you may also have
more interesting tasks.
I mean obviously this is engineering,
so you'll have mathematical expressions,
you'll have tables of data
that you need to extract
and you need to do that well.
It's not good enough
that you get close
enough in these systems.
So you have these different
processing pipelines.
In the end they make that
available to the agent
through, for example, Amazon
Bedrock Knowledge Bases.
If you need more of a like
the traditional RAG approach.
But again, this can be combined
with multi-step reasoning
later on in the agents.
On top of the, if you
need a structured search
through semantic search,
you can use Amazon Bedrock Knowledge Bases
for example on OpenSearch Serverless.
If you need more information
about the entities,
how they relate to each other,
a graph database is a good choice
and that's also used in the system.
And lastly, you may want to
use some ad hoc analytics
or other structured queries
and you can use Amazon Redshift in there.
Also all of this can actually be behind
the Amazon Bedrock Knowledge Base,
which can make it relatively easy
for you to get started with that.
But sometimes you need a
little bit more customization
as we've done in this case.
All right, next piece.
So we have the right
data where we need it.
There is other parts though, right?
I already hinted at there is
a custom large language model
that has to be trained.
Why does it has to be trained?
Well, Ericsson provides or
creates their own hardware,
their own silicon.
That silicon, well you have your own
proprietary frameworks and
language on top of that.
So helping your engineers
with off the shelf large language models
for coding related task
is just not gonna gonna do the trick.
You need to be able to
produce the right content
and in that case, Ericsson realized
it's important to train
our own model on that,
and this is what we have on this slide.
I'm not gonna go into
super much detail here.
This is yet another two day session
if we want to go into detail.
But suffice to say,
you need to source code,
you need system documentation
or code documentation for that.
You need to run it through
a pre-processing pipeline
to get high quality
data asset for training,
in this case, this is done
with continued pre-training,
instruct fine tuning,
and reinforcement learning
with human feedback on top of that
to get the best possible model
that you can then host on,
depending on the different models
'cause there's always a change
in what's the best model.
Sometimes that works well on
Bedrock Custom Model Import
and other times it's hosted on EC2.
And then of course evaluation is king,
so this is something
that you constantly evaluate and retrain.
Moving on to the last architecture slide
where I want to just bring the whole thing
a little bit together.
How does it look at runtime?
Let's start with the engineer again.
The engineer, well again,
they want to use it
where it makes sense,
where they work.
So either in a dedicated front end
or you use it through
Amazon Q Developer or Kiro.
The point of that is that, well,
how do you utilize that,
how do you actually integrate that?
Or use the MCP gateway that
Ericsson has created for that,
the MCP gateway can then surface tools
for the assistance that we
have on the left side here
for the network engineer.
It can be agents and the
MCP gateway is actually
the integration point where
agents can talk to tools,
agents can talk to agents
and even tools could well talk to agents.
Both of the tools that we have there,
sometimes it's a tool that already exists
and you just want to make it available
and you could do that
through AgentCore Gateway, for example,
sometimes it may be an
original MCP server or a tool,
and then you can run that
on the AgentCore Runtime.
The AgentCore Runtime is
mainly used however now
for running agents,
and here's just a selection
of different agents
that we have here.
So maybe it is a 3G PP agent,
maybe an agent that is more specialized
in a specific feature.
So you have LTE experts for example,
that you're running there,
plenty of other specialized agents.
And then you have, for example,
the code generation agent,
which then in turn,
and you look to the
right side of this slide,
you'll see that we have integration
with large language models,
and agent obviously is
just a piece of code
that needs to integrate
within large language model
for orchestration.
And here you can either fall back
on the many models available on Bedrock
as a model provider,
or you can use your custom models.
And again, AgentCore,
the beauty of that is
it's super flexible,
so if you do have a
on-prem model for example,
you can integrate that
easily there as well.
All right, last piece,
agents needs knowledge
and they can integrate
with many of the different
knowledge layers here.
It's relatively easy here,
for example, if you use a
agent framework like Strands,
you can relatively easy integrate directly
into, for example, the
Bedrock Knowledge Bases.
Right, this wraps up the main pieces
of the architecture here,
but then you have observability,
again, that's important we
said a couple of times now.
AgentCore observability
makes this possible,
it's compatible with OpenTelemetry,
it's very easy to look at
the entire end-to-end stack
of your application
and it makes a lot of
sense if you integrate it
with other APM traces that you have
maybe across the entire stack.
And the entire stack means,
well there's applications,
frontend applications,
there's lambdas here and there,
there's containers running there and there
so you want to have an
entire picture of that,
and that's why observability is important,
specifically for agent traceability,
you have AgentCore
Observability as a primitive.
Then we also said identity is important,
so you need to make sure
that an agent can only do
what they're supposed to do.
AgentCore Identity makes
it possible you to manage
inbound and outbound
identities so you can make sure
that the agents and the users
can only get to what they need to
and you can go all the way down
to the role level
authorization of your data
in your data sources.
And last but not least, memory.
Memory wraps it up.
I mean, getting the right context
for your agent is important
and sometimes you want to
transport it over sessions
so memory is one of
the pieces that is used
to transport preferences
and topics across sessions.
So AgentCore was core, right?
- So-
- Of course.
- I have a quote here,
but I think it's better if you
just maybe narrate this one.
- Right, so thank you Bastian.
Great to see the work of
the lab kind of compressed.
I mean we're quite serious.
I mean this is quite a
big challenge to take,
sort of the complexity that we face
when we look at mobile
network in deployment,
or in engineering, right?
And all of that complexity
and sort of how do we actually, you know,
pull together all these pieces
so that we tackle the challenge
that I post there, right?
With the frontier of AI
advancing much faster
than the out of the box
kind of industrial use cases
of AI do.
So we've been throwing requirements
towards Bastian and the AWS team.
I mean, I would say almost,
I mean to test you maybe a little bit?
No, not quite, but to really
push the collaboration
to a new gear.
And so that ended up being sort of
one of the drivers for AgentCore
that for us is the foundation
where we can sort of say,
okay, let's get help at
this knowledge fusion layer
and get, I mean, again, to kind
of drink our own champagne,
to take complexity out, right?
So we don't wanna be in the business
of running Kubernetes clusters,
much rather have that
offloaded to the Core platform
and sort of AgentCore has been a key piece
of how we we scale.
Good.
- Thank you so much.